hey Conan O'Brien here and I got some
exciting news people say that all the
time and then they don't have anything
really to say but I got something good
to say so I'm actually telling the truth
this year weird Comic Con and as always
we are featuring four new Funko pop
figures this is pretty cool check it out
this year spider-man I'm a reboot and
just like me it has the body of a 15
year old boy check this one out
Star Wars and look it even comes with a
little Star Wars logo right there
because without it I get sued so we keep
that baby on huh can't get me now look
at this Lewis is the flash his power is
that he's very speedy I don't know I
never quite bought that but I still love
you gotta love the flash you got to get
this one you really have to get this one
and then if you're a game of Thrones fan
check it out white Walker this is
basically modeled on me not wearing a
shirt at the beach so these are cool
these are available if you watch my show
you will be able to get one of these and
true story every year people gobble
these up and then they're on eBay for
thousands of dollars that means within
the decade each one will be worth
millions of dollars that's just math
okay peace out Tupac I don't know Comic
Con
you